اذا بعد ثمانيه اشهر من المعارك الطاحنه
يبدو الوضع وكان المواقع تتبدل بين من
سيطر على المدينه ومن يحاصرها قوات فاجنر
اعلنت انها استحوذت على المدينه بالكامل
على ان تسلمها للجيش الروسي يوم الخميس
وفق تقرير لنيويورك تايمز وعلى مدار
اسابيع ابتكر الجنود الاوكرانيون
استراتيجيه للهجوم اثناء تبديل المناوبه
بين وحدات عناصر فاجنر وهو توقيت يمثل
نقطه ضعف كبيره للمجموعه العسكريه وللحفاظ
على عنصر المفاجاه اعتمد الاوكرانيون على
الهجوم عبر الجنود المشاه بينما اقتصر
استخدام المدفعيه على التلال والمرتفعات
التي تسيطر عليها القوات الاوكرانيه لقصف
قوات فاجنر هذه الاستراتيجيه مكنت
اوكرانيا من استعاده قطعه ارض بعرض ثلاثه
كيلو مترات جنوب قريه
او خارج مساحه قد تبدو صغيره الا ان
الاوكرانيين اعتمدوا على نجاحهم واستعادوا
اكثر من 20 كيلومترا مربعا شمال وج
المدينه وفقا للجيش هذه المكاسب
الاوكرانيه تمثل ضربه محتمله لجهود
الحربيه الروسيه التي جعلت من باخ مونتاج
جائزه الاستراتيجيه الاساسيه لها وعلى
جانب الاوكراني فان استعاده هذه الاراضي
قد يساعد كياف او تساعد كياف في الوقت
الذي تتاهب فيه لهجومها المضاد من خلال
اضعاف القوات الروسيه في عده نقاط على طول
الجبهه ايضا اشارت نيويورك تايمز الى ان
اوكرانيا تستغل الانقسامات العلنيه بين
الافرع المسلحه الروسيه من جيش وقوات
فاجنر وقوات شيشانيه لتحقيق تقدم على
الارض وان كان محدودا نسبيا الجيش
الاوكراني قال ان عشرات الاشتباكات تدور
كل يوم في المنطقه وان جنوده سيواصلون
محاوله التقدم بشكل مستمر يفهم من هذا
الكلام ان بخنوت لا تزال غير محسومه
بالكامل لكن كان الاوكرانيون داخلها اما
الان فتغير الوضع بناء على التصريحات
الروسيه وبات الروس في الداخل لمتابعه
المزيد من
الاخ قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر
الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات